(film projector humming)
- We're pro hiders,
professionals at hiding.
We hide fast and we hide long.
(smooth jazz music)
My brother and I have over 75
years of hiding experience.
Collectively, we
have over 3,500 hides
and virtually no
premature discoveries.
Each hide presents its
own set of challenges.
A pro needs a strong
will, lots of patience,
and an enormous bladder.
Now, that's a hide right there.
The lumber slumber.
It's all splinters
and wood rats.
Some of the places
we've hidden out are
the Middle East,
the Academy Awards,
and in a moose carcass.
We haven't seen our
dad in over 20 years.
That's how good he is.
My brother is attempting
one of the most
difficult hides of his career,
the supermarket stowaway.
I've shaved on a hide,
ate full-course meals on a hide,
I met my wife on a hide.
That's a textbook hide.
A hider is discrete
and courteous.
That's not a hide.
Just going to the bathroom.
A cereal shelf makes a
great bed and breakfast.
Professional hiders,
here today, gone today.
For more information on
joining the Little Hiders Club,
send a picture of
your favorite hide
in a self-addressed envelope
to Professional Hiders at
World Taekwondo Headquarters.
(filmstrip buzzing)